[Music]
he was just
this young raw insane talent who's
probably going to be one of the best
players in the name
twist they're looking up they're not
even looking down they don't clear the
corner and almanac had no
idea twists what has like an incredible
amount of talent and just a lot of work
ethic
position now for the peak on destiny
beautiful stuff
towards the end absolutely glorious
clutch from twist
twist is he's an insane bragger man
every event he's just delivering and
luring
and twisting the corner there should be
no way out my god
how has he done it picking up a quick
triple and he's going to win the round
absolutely godlike
i remember i was showing her like video
clips of like esl cologne i remember
telling her like
if you let me pursue like pursue this
i'll be there one day
he peeked out ak available he's going to
grab it on the run and he's got the bomb
he's got armor
this is a straight one on two but alex
is close twist he fights about somehow
a third he's got confidence in his name
and he sees it
once and twist shows us all the maple
syrup is just another form of liquid
otherwise it has to be on the a site
they're gonna wrap back at least he does
enough damage though that gives twist
the chance
crimson slow and twist will close out
the round i don't know i was just never
happy
life how outside of the computer wasn't
that good he's got
nothing to work with except this rifle
he gets the headshot
turning it around and no he picks it up
it's
over time straight into the hot and out
to the a site
already getting locked out of his twist
ridiculously four headshots
the guy's skill level is unbelievable
for me in terms of pure skill he's the
enemy equivalent to simple
this is the guy who's just superlative
in terms of what he's able to do oh my
god he's done it
a twist indeed because liquid are gonna
pick up a round they had no business
winning
growing up in kelowna british columbia
video games were a huge part of russell
twist van dulken's family life
i think it was a way to build like a
fall or song
bond like we i don't know we played like
everything together
like even even rock band i feel like it
was the best way i could connect with
him
if he wasn't playing games he was
working twist spent much of his
childhood watching his dad play video
games and it started playing quake
himself
my first fps was quake i don't know what
happened but i think they just let me
uh play quake with him because he they
knew it's like i was always watching him
he had a big influence on me playing
video games i mean he's the one that
basically
started it for me and then when twist
was 13 his father who'd already been
separated from his mother for some time
moved away entirely
it felt as if twists had lost his best
friend so like she didn't care if i was
like constantly sitting there playing
games
somewhat didn't care if i was like not
doing my homework all she cared about
was seeing me laugh and see me have fun
on my pc
and seeing me be myself because i was
not myself
like at school or around other people
since his days in elementary school
twist had been the victim
of bullying in school i was bullied a
lot throughout
most of my middle school years i mean i
was only in high school for one year so
i can't really say anything about that i
don't know i was just never happy
but after moving in with his mom and her
boyfriend twists turned his attention
to a new game
[Music]
ces quickly became twist's newest
obsession and served as an escape from
the perils of his everyday life
her weight her like vision on like me
playing games always
was like it was like a babysitter for me
while twist's mother was happy to see
him so invigorated
her boyfriend didn't understand twist's
love for the game
and it wasn't long before that lack of
understanding turned into verbal
abuse so even when i went home i felt
like i was still being judged and
bullied
like no matter what i did fearing for
their safety they packed their bags
and left it was only then when he and
his mother had fashioned a new healthier
home life that twists was able to throw
himself into counter-strike completely
probably the best thing that my parents
did for me or was my mom
was to let me play like every day
because she thought like the computer
was like my babysitter and that she
always knew where i was
and i was never in trouble so that's one
thing that i'm probably most thankful
for is
she just let me sit there for 10 to 12
hours a day playing video games
by the time he was 14 twists had already
made a name for himself in the north
american cs scene
and was regarded as something of a
prodigy he joined tectonic in october
2015 before making his esl pro league
debut with team agg
in early 2016 making him the first
professional player
to be born after the creation of the
original counter-strike mod
and then in march of 2016 it happened
twists got his first break and joined
team solomid's new north american roster
you want to see if someone's difficult
because my mom looked at this contract
and didn't really know what to do as
like a parent figure because like she
saw a bunch of things she's like salary
she saw like a time
frame and i remember i was showing her
like video clips of like esl cologne and
everything like the stage i remember
telling her like
if you let me pursue like pursue this
i'll be there one day
like i'll work so hard for this so let
me do it his first stop
the ecs season one finals and a
foreshadowing face-off against astralis
i feel that twists and sick are two of
maybe
four or five players that i really think
are going to be the the next stars of
the
na scene and the twists obviously
because he he's only 16. in twist's
first ever round at an international
land
he found himself in a 1v2 against device
and dupree
everyone was looking at twists to prove
himself and
well quick that will help his device
hits the shots far off twist
the young player on tsm too young even
for the e-league can't manage to land it
so they'll get the full 10 second defuse
and
astralis will pick up the first round
the worst part is that it happened again
not two rounds later one versus two only
19 hp to work with
there we go then twist 19 hp needs to be
to the side together there it is win the
round but this kid
had some fight in him he opens up the
map there for tsm gets the first entry
kill on the drop down area picks up the
off as well gets the second is twist
another three kills with him great
performance so far tsm went on to beat
astralis and despite losing to an
unstoppable luminosity in the main event
landed themselves a top four finish
still in awp to go against him and
cold's gonna win the angle
16 14 it is in luminosity right through
to the right straight through excuse me
to the grand finals
you say goodbye to tsm but what a
tournament it's been for them what a
fairy tale story turning up
the complete underdog no i expected
anything from them unfortunately
tsm would never achieve anything of note
after that
and twists spent the next six months
training while he waited for another
opportunity similar to that of his
teammate automatic
who'd been given the chance to join
cloud9 in august
come april 2017 he got it
following the players rights debacle
that took place earlier that year in
which twists and his teammates left tsm
in order to continue playing with sean
guerras on misfits
he was offered the chance to join team
liquid it's a dream come true to be
playing on team liquid
being a 17 year old player and playing
on a tier one team feels
great i feel like i'm actually the
youngest player playing at this like
like competition levels makes me feel
like i have something to prove against
like
tier one europeans following the
departure of their ukrainian phenom
simple liquid were eager to usher in yet
another soon-to-be superstar
a prodigy who would blossom into cs go's
next world-class talent
and as far as liquid were concerned that
player was twists
my impression of twist before he joined
the team was that he was just
this young raw insane talent who's
probably going to be one of the best
players in nate i know eventually he's
going to be super super good probably
like the best player in any by far
you know maybe a few months or so guys
going places he's gonna
definitely be in the top of any or if
not the world on paper liquid had the
potential to be a top
level team and they were at first as
they're completely
and surrounded will flank it
liquid to the finals cloud nine to play
off against faze
one north american team through and for
the second week in a row they take down
the number one rated team in the world
the issue was that they were
inconsistent
after making top four at the esl pro
league season five finals
they took second at both esg mykonos and
esl one new york
then in a stunning turn of events they
bombed out of the e-league premiere
and epicenter over the course of 2017 it
became apparent that liquid
had the pieces to be one of the world's
best but they simply couldn't figure out
how to put them together
their in-game leader stanislaw wasn't
quite meshing with the team's play style
and jdm wasn't the opera he once was
despite cracking into the top tier at a
slew of premier events
twists simply couldn't carry his
teammates to a championship
still he was putting up staggering
performances and was quickly developing
a reputation
for being one of the most underrated
players in the game
come the new year liquid's humiliating
12th 14th finish at the boston major
made it clear that the team was in
desperate need of a change
they kicked jdm in favor of naf and
having had virtually no time to practice
they made their mark at cs summit 2.
still no kids anywhere oh my god he's
going to find the kit he's not going to
get a 10 second defusing
oh there it is nitro with a white okay
to finish things off and liquid are your
cs summit two champions
coming to the starladder season four
finals twists had approached
new levels of insanity straight into the
heart and out to the east side
already getting locked out of a twist
ridiculously four headshots you have to
run through a molotov steel on the site
that's an easy kill and everyone's just
kind of stopped cold
and now twist the magnificent van dulken
with a magnificent double kill and
they're gonna keep doing this twist
we'll get one more headshot
there he is with a double looking for
the triple he's such a good pistol
player
and that's gonna leave guardian in the
open one versus two twist will take him
down
having benched stannis lost several
months earlier liquid recruited steel in
his stead before enlisting the help of
one of the game's most accomplished
support players
taco is a two-time major champion
11-time world champion
i don't know how many finals he's been
in we couldn't find someone more
experienced for
the one-to-one trade in the role with
taco at their side liquid quickly
solidified themselves as north america's
strongest roster
and through it all twists was becoming
the superstar
everyone predicted he would
[Music]
by april 2018 everything pointed towards
liquid finally
becoming a true international contender
one of the best
rosters in the world the problem was
that counter-strike was about to enter a
starry new era
one in which the best liquid could ever
hope for was second place
back-to-back pro league martial
season seven chicago and now for the
first time ever at home
season eight i've strolled into the
champions of esl pro league and for the
first time in history the best of all
[ __ ] time until grand slam it
destroys
going into the london major twists had
lost three consecutive grand finals to
astralis
so when he matched up against them in
the semi-finals he was hoping to change
the narrative
so they know how we play uh as long as
said in interviews
it seems like we're just a replica of
them and that's because we didn't have
much time to practice
this time around if we get them the
three of stage i think we're gonna beat
them but astralis were unstoppable
nap versus zips m4 in hand one smoke to
work with
there's a kit inside of the site but
he's gotta find that in zipfix
he could play the sound you can sit this
back smoke goes on it
not on the kid he's gonna have to try
and play this ten seconds has to take
the fight and zips got it instead
to defend the ramp first makes a little
bit of noise here he's trying to bait in
his teammate there you can see it's zip
x
on the left hand side they're trying to
work together first kill successful for
the cts it's all falling apart ramp is
the tightest choke point on the map
got to be very careful up against those
czed zip x
he'll find the bomb no mistake about it
taco's neither where where that came
from and just going to go
up forth as well as he catches out twist
he could start this off with an ace
it would be hard to imagine nitro even
gives him the chance as he gets glaive
down at the very least balm committed to
the site
no chance to retreat back for nitro
[Applause]
just crowds crawling for it one versus
three and he nails it that is a
beautiful start
it quickly became apparent that if
astralis hadn't transformed into the
greatest team in cs go history
liquid would probably be the number one
in the world the issue is that even when
they weren't playing astralis liquid
couldn't win a grand final
to save their lives he knows where the
bomb is he knows there's a smoke on it
he's got it no he doesn't he doesn't
sonny's got away with it now sports win
it the battle of brooklyn
and they're back to winning after the
roster change after so much work
and his heartbreak for liquid mouse
sports and esl one despite earning his
first
mvp medal at the esl one new york final
twists couldn't prevent liquid
from suffering an unlikely defeat at the
hands of mouse
never has there been an mvp portrait in
which the recipient
looked this disappointed twist went on
to lose two more grand finals to
astralis before the end of 2018
but was still ranked among hltv's top
players of the year
twists he hasn't got that much excuse in
the game still
and what's more you look at him as a
player the guy is 19 years old he can
conceivably get even better
if you look at what's happened to the
path of the really god-like european
players like simple
twists can potentially ascend to that
level by now liquid had realized that
if they were to put an end to the danish
super team's dynasty they would need to
shake things up
[Music]
as i'm sure many of you have heard we
are making a couple
roster changes the main thing to discuss
of course is the
trade between zeus and taco for stewie2k
is there any like huge changes between
taco and stew what do you think is the
biggest difference
uh probably uh stewie's more i guess of
a natural leader
so he's a lot to stay usually he doesn't
hold anything back so far
i think actually since stewie joined uh
nick's leading has been way better
following a victory at eye by power
masters that some in the scene
discounted
i hate the fact that people degrade our
win that our power so much
just because some shitty stage doesn't
mean that it was the real game of cs
and we beat them fair and tour man like
we played our hearts out that game
twists prepared for a repeat performance
at the iem katowice major
unfortunately with everyone so fixated
on beating astralis
no one saw the northern lights flashing
in the sky
this could be all she wrote for liquid
20 seconds left
and ali chipped in for a third out of
four
heads of diamond they pulled off the
upset
the better team today and ants
eliminates a tournament favorite
right at the start of the playoffs
following their stunning fifth eighth
finish at the major liquid seemed to
lose a little bit of the momentum they
built up after finally beating astralis
at eye by power in fact come the grand
finals of blast pro series sao paulo
it looked as if liquid had never beaten
them at all real challenge will be
device posted up with the opt
drops nitro first hits the second shot i
mean closing the distance and getting
that bomb in is one thing but you need
the numbers still up from coffins looks
to load liquid
into it sees the shadow easy pickup now
it's 2v2 remember
2v4 from the get-go both these teams
hiding behind barbecue
dupree's position could very well go
unchecked and the counter-terrorists
they're just going to try to cover the
smoke
neither no and now he's going to wildly
spray but the player can't find the bomb
twist has given it up twist missed his
chance to clutch
and that is ten for astralis
i didn't even believe it you know i
really i really didn't
running out of options running out of
time running out of wiggle room
wave easy 2k he's even going to back
himself a third
they just feed themselves into the m4
but then
something important happened astralis
made a conscious decision to lighten
their hectic tournament schedule
skipping certain events in favor of
others for astralis this was an
opportunity to take a breather
for liquid it was an opportunity to
pounce
the thing is despite being regarded by
many as the best player in north america
twists had never actually won
a tier one tournament but that all
changed at iem
sydney but now it's gonna be stewie it
has to get aggressive good find on the
first one best chance for liquid and
it's a one-on-one
smoking when he fires into it and times
it perfectly
let's just spawn out both gets the
information used for bro lane to back
off he finds the head shots as he seems
to do consistently on pistols but
two rolling downs crims next bombs going
forward they have to get the kill on
crimson twists
he's not falling off in this grand final
he does exactly that his 17th kill
catching up tonight who leads on 19.
peter i remind you we need half that
canadian flag back is exist
he wants to rap back through nade to do
damage nitro won't have 100 anymore he's
down to 71.
he's alone exists getting no armor he's
the tactical mind in this but he's got
the incredible
merely got the aim on the twists but he
finds it twists still wait till peak bro
lance spotted
he's got the c set and he's gone it's
all on the jw
smoked away and it's done finally
finally liquid get there not to the
grand slam
[Applause]
the first of four they'll go after the
first tier one event
and stewie is the answer it turns out
after all
sure twist had earned his first tier one
championship and
a second mvp medal but there was one
caveat
astralis had decided to skip that
tournament
dreamhack masters dallas played out
similarly to iem sydney
and he detects threat now he can send
players on the other side there's gonna
be a kill for twist surely he gets the
first
is this where it ends aloe in a three
versus one
but he's got the kill and liquid habit
they've got the championship they've got
masters
and two in the intel grand slam it
created what felt like a tectonic shift
in the world of counter strike after
spending 406 days
at the top of the world ranking astralis
had lost their spot to liquid
but like sydney astralis hadn't attended
dreamhack masters dallas
so come esl pro league season 9 finals
the first tier 1 tournament in which
both liquid and astralis would be in
attendance
it felt as if twists had more to prove
than ever before
if you're liquid and you go into this
game you have to realize wait wait a
minute this is our chance this is now
the beast is bleeding we are feeling
great if we beat them
maybe we have a chance at the third
notch in the grand slam and we can win
the tournament
that has to play into your mind well
it's pulled everyone away from stewie
he's the only one here first shot is his
second shot is his
bomb is his as well and he's got another
one stewie just tears the ball down
it's stewie to ignite team liquid in the
second half
that's gonna be devastating he's
thinking about it but now rifle out
instead he's gonna get the one kill and
yeah this should be a lockdown
sip already low on health nappy's gonna
be going down
10 seconds here and the flank is
happening as well stewie getting a kill
nine seconds and
with the bomb drop dupreeh he's got no
chance at all he's gonna go down to
stewie quad killing him as well
now they're finally gonna put it out and
try and push their way through oh and
it's two for one
then third one nap absolute rock solid
defense
shutting down four players they had
absolutely no chance to make it through
and following it up making it a double
they're lining up for him and he's gonna
take
three with him what a performance oh
twist how is it even possible there's
still a lot of trouble
at this bomb site elise gonna be walking
right on to the site
and taking down glaive and the liege
again he's been a hero this whole game
taking down magus next and nap is gonna
be there at the crossfire
device gets a second one they could do
it already and device he misses a shot
but he's gonna stick it he's gonna stick
the defuse enough got him in the smoke
liquid make their way to the semi-final
a desperate retake is almost there
but naf shuts it down right at the end
twists could finally be considered the
star player of the best team
in the world and in the finals against
g2
he put on the performance of a lifetime
bomb now being picked up by somebody
else's net for the leg shot is it gonna
be quite enough here twist long range
another headshot comes in taking down
shots and that
grinds everything to a hold here for g2
twists can surely get the first one at
the liege will be ready to pounce
twist they're looking up they're not
even looking down they don't clear the
corner
and almanac had no idea that first kill
was so quick
oh what a conversion to pick up the kill
have they done enough g2
it's shocks inside we're gonna get that
fifth back
twist he's on one versus two he tries
for the bomb plant there's surely no way
he could do it
they have got him boxed in right now
he's got nothing to work with
except this rifle he gets the headshot
turning it around and no
he picks it up it's over time this could
be
the final winning moment just him
walking down he's spotting it out he's
gonna be flanking mazda setting up and
that's
an absolute disaster stewie he may have
just done it
double for him and alicia on the other
side oh my god eminek get a one versus
three
with 19 seconds unbelievable scenes here
ladies and gentlemen
team liquid are your season nine pro
league champions
come july a dominant showing at esl one
cologne
saw twists and his teammates secure one
of the most prestigious tournament wins
of the year you're quite emotional right
now
yeah i mean it's one of the greatest
achievements i think vigor is
achievement of
you know north american cs and um i just
think that my mom and dad are watching
this right now it really makes me teary
and i don't know across my team these
guys are awesome and i wouldn't want to
play with anyone else
north american counter strike the
pendulum has swung that way
the kings are dead long live the kings
this is the new era
yeah i think i mean last year we just
lived in a shadow and it gave us all
this drive
and we knew that we're gonna be the best
this year and we're living up to it
with this liquid became the second team
to complete intel's million dollar grand
slam
and it took them only 63 days
it's pretty crazy just how far twists
has come he's gone from a quiet
unassuming kid one who never should have
had a shot in the first place
to arguably the best player in north
america
the guy's skill level is unbelievable
for me in terms of pure skill he's the
na equivalent to simple
this is the guy who's just superlative
in terms of what he's able to do
he's known a lot of adversity life
outside of the computer wasn't that good
even when i went home
i felt like i was still being judged and
bullied like no matter what i did
but with the help of his friends family
and a shitload of resilience
he's managed to become one of
counter-strike's greatest talents
to go from everything he was to
everything he thought he could be
from russell to twists
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you